aquí nos pregunta quién es un consumidor
secundario en este diagrama pausa en el
vídeo y vean si pueden resolver vamos a
verlo juntos pero primero vamos a
asegurarnos de que entendemos muy bien
este diagrama aquí tenemos una flecha
que va del pasto al ratón eso significa
que el pasto va a la boca del ratón es
decir que el ratón se come el pasto el
saltamontes también se come el pasto y
después tenemos estas fechas que van del
ratón al coyote la serpiente el buitre
eso significa que todos estos personajes
se comen el ratón y lo mismo pasa con el
halcón que además se come al saltamontes
bien una vez que entendimos este
diagrama marcamos que el lugar tiene
cada uno de estos personajes en la
cadena alimenticia vamos a ver el pasto
es un productor primario usa la
fotosíntesis para tomar energía luminosa
del sol junto con dióxido de carbono del
aire y agua para almacenar energía
ahora el saltamontes y el ratón se comen
el pasto para obtener esa energía por lo
tanto como el saltamontes y el ratón se
comen directamente al productor primario
podemos decir que son los consumidores
primarios consumidores primarios y tal
vez ya saben a dónde vamos con todo esto
a aquellos que se comen a los
consumidores primarios es decir el
alcohol el coyote el buitre y la
serpiente todos estos son los
consumidores secundarios entonces quién
es un consumidor secundario en este
diagrama bueno el coyote es un
consumidor secundario así como el
alcohol el buitre y también la serpiente
y como pueden ver también existen casos
en donde algunos consumidores
secundarios se comen a otros
consumidores secundarios
el coyote puede comerse a un halcón o el
buitre puede comerse a una serpiente y a
un coyote mientras que la serpiente se
come a un ratón
que a su vez come pasto pero bueno
cualquiera de estos animales se pueden
considerar consumidores secundarios
nos vemos en otro vídeo